in the filmmaking process for Joker was
there one scene maybe toward the
beginning of the principal photography
where you said this is going to be great
and it just energized you and it really
kept you on this like momentum yeah
honestly it was like the first shot
every to the first shot we did shooting
the movie was him at the social workers
scene that is like the second scene in
the movie so when he's laughing
that big laughing spell and then she
starts asking him about you know the job
and and then he's asking like that whole
scene which is like seven or eight pages
or so material actually both social
worker scenes and then when he comes
back the second time and says you never
listen to me all that we shot both those
scenes was like 10 pages of work in one
day not even a long day but that first
take of him performing I went this is
gonna be pretty great like I was like
this movie could be divisive because
it's darker than people expected or
maybe not as funny as they would expect
from Todd or I knew that there would be
some things in which you go we we might
not get all the you know the Batman and
the DC fans on board but what we're
gonna make is gonna be something that
we're gonna be really proud of simply
because I could see it from that
performance and then honestly I was like
I would go home and you know excitedly
show dailies to my wife and just because
I was so excited to show her what we
were doing so I was feeling pretty
strong and pretty like pretty high high
high about the movie all that like from
the beginning and then it was really
motivating because I recognize oh wait
okay so we can't let off the gas ever
like as opposed to like if you start
slowly and you start to get up to speed
and you're like by two weeks and you're
like oh now I understand the movie and
we're gonna start and then you start
like ramping and every day you're like
trying to make it better and better here
I was like oh shoot day 1 was great day
2 - it was great day 3 also great scene
alright now I was like every day has to
be this good and so then it was just
like a it was motivating to
really keep hyper focused on making
something that I thought could be
certainly the best thing Todd and I had
done together and I wanted to be the
best thing I had ever done I just did it
was like a definitely a thing where I
went I just want this to be the best
work I've ever done and so I just stayed
super focus every day to to not let off
the gas so I was feeling pretty hot you
know pretty positive about the movie
right away how much of the film is
improvisational I don't know how much
would be improvisational there's a lot
of improvisation as to like sort of the
way that we don't rehearse and we don't
just put down marks and we don't really
we just start shooting the scene and
sort of witnessing in real time and that
way it's very improvisational as far as
within the body of the scene not a ton
we did some scenes that were just ideas
for things you know that were not
necessarily in the script when we first
started that would just become sort of
ideas that we could do in terms of like
him and the apartment and things like
that but as far as and and and you know
what Keene was certainly fine to kind of
go off the script a little bit in terms
of just like for instance when he stood
up and he's playing with the gun and
he's like talking to himself about like
oh you're a really good dancer you know
that wasn't in the script that just was
happening in real time and you know may
have been discussions with Todd but for
me and my team it was just like this is
happening so let's just you know
photograph it but generally speaking
Todd's not one of those improv guys it
just goes all right now try this and
I'll try that it's if we're gonna change
the script he changes it with the actors
and and the writer and he kind of works
it out a new version of the scene and
then we'll just carry on from there and
shoot that version as opposed to sort of
changing it within the real
improvisation is more in this sort of
technique and and the fluidity in which
me and my camera operator would tell the
story as we would shoot the scenes and
the fact that we you like I said we
wouldn't rehearse or put down marks
those kind of things so we would just
make the movie a bit improvisationally
at times you know which was maybe half
the time was it in the script that at
times you weren't sure was this in
Arthur's mind or was it really happy I
think that's just part of the script
inherently right and part of the fact
that the Joker even in the lore of the
comic books is an unreliable narrator of
his own life so he will tell stories and
it's like was that the truthful story
yeah I think I'm not a big comic book
guy but I know from like reading stuff
and talking to people that he'll tell
backstories about himself in comic books
or graphic novels in which every time he
tells the story it's something different
I think to create this idea that is he
oh is he ever being truthful is any of
it true he's none of it true that kind
of thing so I think inherent to the
script and certainly you're left to sort
of question and ask yourself is that
real was Amy and I obviously we do it
even in within the body of the movie
with the Sophie character and that
relationship to allow us to sort of see
a manifestation of that idea in a in a
relationship that he fantasizes about
and that yet we're seeing it in a way
that it looks like it's happening so I
think it's meant to allow you to have an
interpretation as the audience to decide
what's real and what's not but it's
certainly not something we wanted to key
in and tell the audience precisely what
was real and what wasn't because I think
we want the audience to have their own
interpretation we're in the talk show
like rehearsing for it and and and and
kind of being his best self and then no
spoilers but going there and yeah yeah
it's one of those things that you know
we again the taxi drivers often news is
like a template for the movie and I
think obviously because it's a
disaffected guy who is doing a job and
he sort of strikes out against society a
little bit has some of those
correlations but you know even that
final final scene in taxi driver which
he picks up Cybill Shepherd in the
taxi cab is up for interpretation right
and I don't think when I watched it the
first time I questioned that
interpretation but when I watched it you
know two weeks ago you recognize how
even potentially obvious even this sort
of stylistic aspects of some of the
camera work in that scene could lead you
to believe that like oh did Travis
Bickle die in that shootout in the in
the lair of the prostitute and this
whole PostScript of like him being a
hero and getting the letter from from
Jodie Foster's parents and is that all
just a dream or is that all just you
know a fantasy of like his afterlife or
whatever when I watched it when I was
you know in film school you know back in
college I never you know I didn't
necessarily go to that interpretation
but I recognized that people do so I
think similarly people can do the same
thing here if they choose to
you